corinna bestimmt die regeln in diesen
tagen zweig plus das gilt auch hier das
gilt für die gesamte veranstaltungen
auch wenn sie unter freiem himmel
stattfindet wurde die zahl der gäste die
die bundeskanzlerin heute eingelagert
deutlich reduziert auf etwa 200 auf den
üblichen vor empfang wurde verzichtet
wir sehen jetzt hier gerade angela
merkel die nun auf den platz kommt die
gäste haben bereits platz genommen
die verteidigungsministerien annegret
kramp karrenbauer
karrenbauer an ihrer seite sie ist
sowieso sozusagen die ausrichterin
dieses abends des großen zapfenstreiches
und jetzt wird angela merkel zunächst
eine rede halten das tut nicht jeder
bundeskanzler versorgt heute bei dem
abschied bei helmut kohl haben wir es
erlebt damals in speyer bei gerd
schröder nicht jeder setzt andere
akzente
sie möchte vielleicht auch damit
überraschen weil sie als große rednerin
ja eigentlich nicht in erinnerung
bleiben will aber erwarten wir jetzt
hier so etwas wie eine vermächtnis rede
er eher nicht und nein sie wird nicht
über sich schreiben nicht reflektiert
darüber nachdenken da ist sie kein typ
zu sondern sie wird einfach als bürgerin
ausscheiden am ende und nicht selbst
beurteilen welches vermächtnis
hinterlassen möchte das überlässt sie
journalisten wissenschaftlern aber es
ist ihre vermutlich letzte öffentliche
rede und deshalb natürlich von
besonderem interesse
freunde familie wegbegleiter wir haben
jetzt
angela merkel sehr geehrter herr
bundespräsident
sehr geehrte frau
bundestagspräsidentin
exzellenzen sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe mitbürgerinnen liebe
mitbürger
wenn ich heute hier vor ihnen stehe dann
empfinde ich vor allem dieses
dankbarkeit und demut
demut vor dem amt das ich so lange
ausüben durfte
dankbarkeit für das vertrauen das ich
erfahren durfte
vertrauen dessen bald mir immer bewusst
ist das wichtigste kapital in der
politik
es ist alles andere als
selbstverständlich und dafür danke ich
von ganzem herzen
mein dank gilt auch ihnen frau
bundesministerin lieber annegret und der
bundeswehr für die ausrichtung des
großen zapfenstreichs noch dazu an
diesem in unserer geschichte so
bedeutsamen ort des bendlerblocks
mein dank gilt auch dem stabsmusikkorps
der bundeswehr
für die musikalische begleitung
alles unter den so erschwerten
bedingungen der pandemie
besonders möchte ich deshalb zu beginn
auch an die denken die sich zeitgleich
mit all ihrer kraft der vierten welle
der pandemie entgegenstemmen die alles
geben um leben zu retten und zu schützen
die ärztinnen und ärzte die pflegerinnen
und pfleger in den krankenhäusern die
impf teams die helfenden hände in der
bundeswehr und in den
hilfsorganisationen
ihnen allen gebühren mein und unser
aller besonderer dank und höchste
anerkennung
heute am tage habe ich mit dem
regierungschefin und regierungschefs der
länder noch in einer weiteren pandemie
beratung zusammen gesessen jetzt wenige
stunden später darf ich mich in diesem
feierlichen rahmen nach 16 jahren von
ihnen als bundeskanzlerin verabschieden
wenig zeigt so sehr wie diese abfolge in
welch unglaublicher zeit wir derzeit
leben die 16 jahre als bundeskanzlerin
waren ereignisreiche und oft sehr
herausfordernde jahre sie haben mich
politisch und menschlich gefordert und
zugleich haben sie mich immer auch
erfüllt ganz besonders die vergangenen
zwei jahre der pandemie haben wir in
einem brennglas gezeigt von welch großer
bedeutung das vertrauen in politik
wissenschaft und den gesellschaftlichen
diskurs ist aber auch wie fragil das
sein kann
unsere demokratie lebt von der fähigkeit
zur kritischen auseinandersetzung
und zur selbstkorrektur
sie lebt vom späten ausgleich der
interessen
und von dem respekt voreinander
sie lebt von solidarität und vertrauen
im übrigen auch von dem vertrauen in
fakten und davon dass überall da wo
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis geleugnet
verschwörungstheorien und hetze
verbreitet werden
widerspruch laut werden muss
unsere demokratie lebt auch davon dass
überall da wo hass und gewalt als
legitimes mittel zur durchsetzung
eigener interessen erachtet werden
unsere toleranz als demokratinnen und
demokraten ihre grenze finden muss
die vielfältigen herausforderungen im
innern spiegelt sich auch im
außenpolitischen handeln wieder und zwar
nicht erst seit der pandemie
denn schon die finanz und
wirtschaftskrise 2008 und die vielen
zuflucht suchenden menschen 2015 haben
deutlich gemacht wie sehr wir auf die
zusammenarbeit über nationale grenzen
hinweg angewiesen sind wie unverzichtbar
internationale institutionen und
multilaterale instrumente sind um die
großen herausforderungen unserer zeit
bewältigen zu können den klimawandel
die digitalisierung flucht und migration
ich möchte dazu ermutigen auch zukünftig
die welt immer auch mit den augen des
anderen zu sehen also auch die manchmal
unbequemen und gegensätzlichen
perspektiven des gegenübers wahrzunehmen
sich für den ausgleich der interessen
einzusetzen
meine damen und herren meine politische
arbeit wäre ohne die vielfältige
unterstützung politischer weggefährten
national wie international nicht möglich
gewesen
ihnen allen gilt mein großer dank
ich danke den kolleginnen und kollegen
in der bundesregierung im deutschen
bundestag und im deutschen bundesrat für
unsere zusammenarbeit
ich danke auch für eine politische
streitkultur
um die uns viele andere nationen
beneiden
einen ganz besonderen
herausgehobenen dank schulde ich meinen
engsten mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern danke für alle hilfe und
alle unterstützung und das gilt auch für
meine familie
nun wird es an der nachfolgenden
regierung liegen antworten auf die vor
uns liegenden herausforderungen zu
finden und unsere zukunft zu gestalten
hierfür wünsche ich ihnen lieber olaf
scholz und der von ihnen geführten
bundesregierung alles alles gute und
eine glückliche hand und viel erfolg
ich bin überzeugt dass wir die zukunft
auch weiterhin dann gut gestalten können
werden wir uns nicht mit missmut mit
missgunst mit pessimismus
sondern wie ich vor drei jahren in einem
anderen rahmen gesagt habe mit
fröhlichkeit im herzen an die arbeit
machen so jedenfalls habe ich hier ist
immer für mich gehalten in meinem leben
in der ddr und erst recht und umso mehr
unter den bedingungen der freiheit es
ist diese fröhlichkeit im herzen die ich
uns allen und im übertragenen sinne
unserem land auch für die zukunft
wünsche ich danke ihnen von herzen
[Applaus]
so das war die rede von angela merkel
der scheiben der bundeskanzlerin und
doch ein hauch vermächtnis carola vater
blick auf die krisenkanzlerin die krise
kann das hat sie noch mal dokumentiert
in der auflistung der verschiedenen
krisen aber selbstlos nicht dass ich
spielte eine rolle sondern das team auch
international das multilaterale
und ein klares bekenntnis auch gegen
hass und hetze das wurde auch sehr
deutlich etwas was sie sicherlich sich
auch wünscht dass das bleibt und in
ihrem sinne weiter dagegen gearbeitet
wird so jetzt müssen wir kurz ein
bisschen das prozedere erklären es wird
ein wenig umgebaut werden angela merkel
nimmt jetzt zur abnahme des großen
zapfenstreich auf einem sessel platz
und dann beginnt sozusagen das
zeremoniell roman ich darf sie zu uns
bitten denn sie kennen sich damit am
besten aus wir sehen jetzt hören jetzt
erst mal den einzug es dauert einen
moment und müssen vielleicht noch einmal
sagen wo man wenn man zurückschaut in
die geschichte dann ist dieses
zeremoniell das höchste das festlich
sste was die bundeswehr zu bieten hat
aber das ja in der tradition bis zum
mittelalter zurück zum jahr 1596 zudem
seiten der sa landsknechte in denen ein
verwaltungsbeamter zusammen mit einer
fackel durch die straßen gezogen ist zu
den kneipen und wirten gegangen ist auf
den zapfen geschlagen hatten parallel
dann auch die platzherren haben wir zum
ist daher auch die fackeln und im grunde
ist es ja so was wie wir ein signal an
die soldaten
zur nachtruhe ein aufruf nach hause zu
gehen gefährlich und ins bett genau so
und trotzdem also es ist eine lange
tradition löst es bei manchen doch
merkwürdige assoziationen auslöst heute
gerade wir hatten einen streich vor dem
reichstag fackeln vor dem reichstag da
sagt mancher braucht es diese tradition
löst das nicht falsche assoziationen aus
zeigt auch ein bisschen natürlich die
last der geschichte
immer wieder unterstrich morgen
dazu gehören sollen ausgeschlossen
werden integriert werden gerade in einen
demokratischen prozess die wir heute in
diesen tagen erleben eine friedliche
übergabe damals war ein ganz
heuer kann
jetzt werden wir hier herum an den york
schon mal was richtig traditionell seit
1922 mit einem smart wird der
zapfenstreich gewonnen und der heimat
vollzogen
hamamatsu
[Musik]
fackelträger rechts und links
fackelträger
[Musik]
rechts und links
großer zapfenstreich
gerade
das gewehr
achten rettete das
gemälde auge
frau bundeskanzlerin ich melde großer
zapfenstreich zu ihren ehren angetreten
frau bundeskanzlerin anlässlich des
großen zapfenstreichs zu ihren ehren
überreiche ich ihnen die urkunde des
wachbataillons beim bundesministerium
der verteidigung
so nennt man das war der erste teil der
einleitende teil die aufstellung des
großen zapfenstreiches die meldung und
auch die übergabe der
urkunde und jetzt kommen wir schon zum
zweiten teil richtig so sehen wenn das
ist richtig nämlich zu den musikstücken
die sich die kanzlerin gewählt hat
wird losgehen mit dem ersten lied
nämlich nina hagen du hast den farbfilm
vergessen
von
1974 und wir uns der leiter des
stabsmusikkorps verraten hat 300 yorker
war das eine ziemliche überraschung eine
woche dafür zur einstudierung mussten
erst mal engagiert das arrangement
hergestellt werden und dann musste hier
kräftig geprobt werden das gilt ja so
ein bisschen als so eine etwa subversive
jugendfilme geradezu rankin anarchisch
nur in studentenzeiten sondern auch an
ein system was sie mit denen sie leben
wusste aber sich jetzt in die jugend der
jungen angela merkel zurück die nach
hagen war 19 720
[Musik]
nochmal zu
als den farbfilm vergessen mein michael
ich empfehle ihnen übrigens die die
texte und nachzulesen zdf heute bietet
das natürlich an und jetzt kommt das
zweite gewünschte lied hildegard knefs
hymne für mich soll's rote rosen regnen
wir sollten sämtliche wunder begegnen
das glück sollte sich sanft verhalten es
soll mein schicksal mit liebe verwalten
also zum mitsingen hätte er heute
[Musik]
solche klänge gab es hier glaube ich vor
dem bendlerblock noch nicht sie hat sich
jedenfalls im griff habe gesehen
und in erinnerung an hildegard knef da
vielleicht heute abend auch ein bisschen
mal die war sein jetzt das kirchenlied
das dritte der choral großer gott wir
loben dich
[Musik]
so dass die drei wunsch lieder von
angela merkel eine ddr jugend immer eine
große ballade und ein kirchenlied damit
lässt sich schon ein bisschen in ihr
herz schauen sehr aussagekräftig siehst
du unkonventionelle frau und
konventionelle politikerin so hat sie
das auch ausgewählt es ist ihre ddr was
seite die sich in den letzten jahren
stärker gemacht hat auch in
verschiedenen regen dokumentiert er
zuletzt am dritten oktober die sie in
den jahren zuvor nicht so präsentiert
hat es ist natürlich die pfarrerstochter
die hier mit dem religions- lied noch
mal dass auch unterstreicht das ist das
dienende das ist das kultur
protestantische was sie mit eingebracht
hat in die gefahren der macht auch immer
zu verzichten
[Musik]
so jetzt beginnt das eigentliche
kernstück roman kann man glaube ich
sagen der große zapfenstreich mit seinen
vier teilen einmal das locken als
dargestellt mit den trommlern soll das
schlagen auf den zapfenstreich
darstellen dann der mass für die
fußtruppen dann direkt für die
kavallerie und am ende der ruf zum gebet
und
dann hören wir jetzt mal dieses locken
das sind ja flötentöne flöten signale
und trommel
das wird jetzt losgehen ja
[Musik]
so das war jetzt so etwas wie das
herzstück des großen zapfenstreiches
oder sondern human also haben wir das
gehört zuletzt die hre treibt also der
ruf für die kavallerie sozusagen dann
wieder das locken das ist eine
festgefügte abfolge genau diese
festgelegte abfolge des großen
zapfenstreiches ist seit 1873 fester
bestandteil und schließt jetzt am ende
mit dem gebet wie peter an die macht der
liebe und am ende seit 1922 mit der
deutschen nationalhymne also das sind
jetzt quasi die nächsten punkte die
folgen
[Musik]
zum gebet
liebe in der kann man schon sagen
modernen auslegungen durchaus nicht nur
christliches gebet sondern eine
einladung er zum innehalten zur andacht
egal welcher religion der oder die
einzelne angehört
[Musik]
was her
red
wolfgang bis wann haben wir zeit bis 1
[Musik]
zwtl
augen
ich melde ende des großen
zapfenstreiches
augen gerade
das gewehr
wer
fackelträger
fackelt recht und links
wackelt
so jetzt hat der kommandeur
oberstleutnant keine bänke der
kommandeur des bataillons des
verteidigungsministeriums den großen
zapfenstreich wieder abgemeldet jetzt
erfolgt ausmaß
noch ein paar minuten dauern sowas
nochmal alles gut gegangen oder
normal gewesen selbstverständlich
denn
vielleicht einmal noch sagen dass für
sie persönlich durchaus da auch ein
kreis schließt heute abend sind die
gesamte kanzler von angela merkel
ihr als teil des wachbataillons dabei
gewesen am ersten dezember 2005 bei
ihrem allerersten einsatz weichen waffen
zugführer eingeteilt beim
ministerpräsidenten singapurs er damals
an der fahne vorbei gelaufen ist und
dann den zweiten einsatz
ministerpräsidenten indien in hannover
dürfte ich selbst kommandieren und heute
bei ihrem abschluss sei aber das ist
wirklich eine klammer die sie schließt
wovon streich
wow
[Musik]
wenn wir jetzt wieder den
marsch nicht schon genommen ein zu
kennen
[Musik]
so
viel auszug wenn wir hier angela merkel
auch immer wieder sehen um uns sehr zu
bedanken roman dankeschön für die
erläuterung von ihren noch aus während
dieses abends und bündeln vielleicht
noch mal ein bisschen
mit professor karl rudolf korte bisschen
lohnt sicher bilanz zu ziehen viele
andere auch an diesem abend
beginnt vielleicht nochmal einmal damit
wie angela merkel musikalisch gestaltet
hat das waren überraschung hat er jetzt
im vorfeld schon dafür gesorgt dass
große auslegungen veröffentlicht wurden
vielleicht darf man es aber auch gar
nicht so überbewerten vielleicht nein
weil sie ja zur selbstironie immer neu
und kommt man solche dinge liebt und uns
immer wieder überrascht trotz ihrer
uniformiert hat auch so wie sie
gekleidet ist wie sie in ihrer bis zur
schmerzgrenze nüchternheit uns immer
wieder konfrontiert mit diesem dienen
momentum gibt es eben auch in diesem tag
anders zur fröhlichkeit hat sie ja
selbst auch gesagt und so ist auch die
auswahl über das man vielleicht nicht
über argumentieren sollte und was hier
alles hinein zu interpretieren wäre weil
die fröhlichkeit des herzens glaube ich
das wird dann auch noch in erinnerung
bleiben als der ausspruch jetzt beginnt
ihre arbeit als politikwissenschaftler
die arbeit der historiker und bilanz zu
ziehen und die frage geben wird sein was
bleibt wir sehen jetzt dass angela
merkel zusammen mit annegret kramp
karrenbauer hier noch den ausmarsch des
großen zapfenstreiches abwartet sie wird
dann abgeholt werden mit einem mit einer
wagenkolonne und zurück ins kanzleramt
gefahren werden es ist
dann einer ihrer letzten öffentlichen
auftritte sie wird noch in der
unionsfraktion am dienstag
erwartet
keine auslandsreisen mehr nur aus
sichtlich und dann wird ja mitte
nächster woche so ist es geplant die
amtsübergabe stattfinden also was bleibt
von dieser kanzlerschaft 60 jahre schon
eine muss man ja fast sagen
außergewöhnliche spektakuläre naja jetzt
wird ja auch geklatscht er zu recht
viermal ist gewählt worden die
sicherheits deutschen fühlen sich gut
aufgehoben von ihr konzerten sie nicht
immer wieder gewählt ein
stabilitätsanker ein vertrauens
versprechen für viele menschen da werden
auch verlustängste sich ausbreiten trotz
des normalen wechsels der zu demokratie
dazugehört aber das besondere dieses
tages ist natürlich auch dass sie die
erste kanzlerin ist die darauf
verzichtet hat nochmal anzutreten sie
ist nicht abgewählt worden sie hat also
jetzt die einmalige chance das schwerste
für ein politiker würde voll
bedeutungslos zu werden und das wird sie
angehen wir sanieren ihr mann an ihrer
seite joachim sauer tja was werden die
beiden jetzt machen das ist ja die große
frage sie hat immer gesagt ich schlafe
erst mal aus und denke danach was
erwarten sie beim bc als
vortragsreisender wieder erleben ich
glaube auch er nicht als normale
bürgerin an der kasse beim einkaufen
wenn wir sie erleben so unprätentiös so
öffentlich und war sie immer und diese
rolle wird sie auch übernehmen das hat
sie ja in den vorgängern auch immer
kritisiert und in diesem falle wird sie
nicht gehen da bin ich ziemlich sicher
die beiden müssen erstmal wieder lernen
zweisamkeit zusammen zu sein neue
wirklichkeit zu zweit
rote rosen für mich soll's rote rosen
regnen war einer der gewünschten titel
heute
die waren für sie bestimmt eine nimmt
sie mit einem verschenkt sie ich habe
vielleicht war es auch ein liebesliedern
irgendwann
auch das ist ja möglich
so ich glaube man sieht was sieht man
zufriedenheit schon zwischendurch sah
man durchaus auch mal rührung muss man
sagen ja sie war ergriffen bei dem helm
ab lied das hat man eindeutig gesehen
und das ist sehr selten bei ihr
emotionaler aktuell dass sie sieht sich
selbst als oberste sachbearbeiterin
dieses landes und da gestattet sie sich
auch keine leidenschaft
sie haben es gesagt professor karte die
erste frau in diesem amt
auch die ärzte die geschafft hat
selbstbestimmt sozusagen aus dem amt zu
gehen also nicht abgewählt zu werden und
das ist schon das besondere wird es eine
ära merkel dann am ende sein auch in den
geschichtsbüchern auf jeden fall so eine
kulturelle zäsur der merkel ismus hatte
einen bestimmten politik begriff geprägt
situativ zu agieren
reaktiv zu agieren nicht das große
gestalten sondern eher die wirklichkeit
verliebtheit auch nicht die großen
diskussion öffentlich deswegen war das
heute interessant zu hören dass sie
diese große streitkultur sich wünscht in
ihrer zeit vor allem mit den großen
koalition gab es sie eher eine diskurs
allergie hier die zeit geprägt wir
müssen ja erst wieder lernen auch zu
streiten über unterschiedliche ziele
also empörung resistent wie sie vorging
nüchtern bis an die schmerzgrenze ein
begriff von politik der auch mit ihrer
person zusammenhängt sie ist als person
nie fähig zu polarisieren und daran sind
auch manche andere wahlkämpfer
verzweifelt
wir sagen ja gerade noch mal einige der
gäste wir sagen den bundespräsidenten
mit seiner
ehefrau
auch ein ehemaliger vizekanzler ist hier
zu sehen rösler das war der frühere
fdp-chef
und ohnehin sind die ministerinnen und
minister aus vier kabinetten angela
merkel hier heute eingeladen gewesen das
sind allein dann auch schon über 50
personen
whistler in der
im schwarz gelben kabinett
ja das ungewöhnlich ist ja dass sie
diese drei großen koalition geführt hat
in dem für die geschichte der republik
ungewöhnlich aber mit ihrer a zu führen
als kanzler präsidentin geradezu
idealtypisch die kraft der macht durch
moderation das hatte sie kohl abgeguckt
und das hat sie auch gezielt eingesetzt
und so hat sie auch mit ganz
unterschiedlichen akteuren zusammen
sehr intensiv mit unterschiedlichen
koalitionen und mit einem vermutlich ja
weiblichen kommunikations und
führungsstil auch alles zusammengehalten
ja und sie hat das hat war auch
außergewöhnlich beim g20-gipfel in
rohren quasi eine amtsübergabe
international auf internationaler bühne
organisiert für ihren nachfolger olaf
scholz
hatte man vorher auch noch nie so
gesehen nein dann vizekanzler wird ja
auch nicht danach automatisch kanzler
halten eine demokratie ist es ja eher
ungewöhnlich bis zum zweiten mal nach
willy brandt das überhaupt ein
vizekanzler dann die chance erhält
gewählt zu werden als kanzlerkandidat
angetreten aber das war mehr als nur
eine geste ist war ein zeichen der
qualität unserer demokratie die uns auch
international immer wieder große
beachtung die uns damit wir
international auch verbunden weil wir
doch hier eine art von sozialen
gesellschaftlichen frieden auf hohem
niveau organisiert haben und eine sehr
breite in der mitte ausformuliert aus
formierte gesellschaft und das ist oft
beneidenswert aus dem ausland das vieh
polarisiert agiert ist also eine
umarmung und konsensdemokratie hier viel
stärker als in anderen ländern das ist
richtig hat nicht zu extrem
wahlergebnissen geführt und es gibt
jetzt vor weihnachten wie versprochen
eine regierung der künftige kanzler hat
jedenfalls in den letzten tagen auch
deutlich gemacht ich übernehme und will
aktiv für eine pressekarte ganz vielen
dank für begleitung dieses abends eine
16-jährige kanzlerschaft das können wir
ja noch bemerken geht zu ende den rekord
von helmut kohl hat sie nicht
eingestellten tage die historische
politische aufarbeitung beginnt jetzt
und sie wird stärken und schwächen
zeigen die letzte krise corona spielt
die heute auch eine rolle hat angela
merkel bis zuletzt gefordert und
verhindert schon jahre als lame duck zu
gelten hat aber zugleich auch ihre
schwindende macht offenbart mit
konsequenzen die korona krise wird jetzt
die erste große herausforderung für
ihren nachfolger olaf scholz
oder scholz ein mann aus dem westen die
frau aus dem osten geht nach einer
spektakulären karriere angela merkel die
ein erstes leben hatte als
wissenschaftlerin in der ddr und ein
zweites als kanzlerin des vereinigten
deutschlands
wir danken ihnen sehr für ihre
aufmerksamkeit in der letzten stunde
bleiben sie gesund und wir verabschieden
sie jetzt gerne mit den bildern dieses
abends ist aus berlin
[Musik]